il poursuit en revanche une carrière
beaucoup plus obscures pendant des
années il est l'homme de main de la
famille hornec les parrains de montreuil
des grands noms du banditisme
ça fait peur l'homme de main auraient
trempé dans des affaires beaucoup plus
graves notamment l'escroquerie à la taxe
carbone
cette fois ci il n'est plus question de
petits raquette mais d'énormes sommes
d'argent et de règlements de comptes en
série
cap d'ail petite ville frontalière de la
principauté de monaco
c'est ici sur la corniche que sofiane
dridi vient courir tous les jours
juste avant noël la vie du jeune homme a
basculé son père avec qui il vivait elle
a élevé seule a été assassiné à 23 ans
sofiane est désormais seul
jeu se retrouver avec des
des réels problèmes d'adultes alors que
23 ans c'est pas facile à gérer je sais
pas je sais pas ce que sera fait demain
donc je vais au jour le jour
juste après le drame il a trouvé refuge
sur la côte d'azur où il s'entraîne en
attendant de signer un contrat comme
footballeur professionnel
encore une chance que j'ai la
possibilité de faire du football les
ce que sinon honnêtement je crée je fais
je serai pas
je pense que je n'arriverai pas à m'en
sortir
moi je voyais comme quelqu'un
d'indestructible l'a connu énormément de
galère c'en est toujours relevé donc je
me suis dit voilà
c'est pas possible
c'était en décembre dernier mohamed
dridi 48 ans est tué par balles dans
l'appartement où il vivait avec son fils
à palavas les flots à côté de
montpellier
mohamed dridi c'est un personnage
sulfureux
ancien champion du monde de kickboxing
hommes de main du grand banditisme amis
de la jet set il se fait connaître du
public en écrivant sa biographie un
livre au parfum de scandale qui fait
sensation depuis quelques années il
affirmait avoir quitté le milieu du
banditisme et s'être rangée alors que
s'est il passé
retour sur le parcours d'un homme à la
vie hors normes dans une affaire où se
mêlent box bracket et show-business
lundi 5 décembre 2016 palavas les flots
se réveille doucement à cette époque de
l'année la petite cité balnéaire est
déserte c'est ici au dernier étage de
cette résidence
que vive mohamed dridi et son fils vers
8h30 comme tous les matins sofiane par
faire son jogging sur la plage
quand je suis parti ils n'avaient pas la
télé allumée dormait et généralement
quand il sait que je vais courir soit il
m'envoie un texto pendant que je coure
juste avant que je commence à courir en
me disant cour bien une heure une heure
et demie
il l'avait toujours un petit truc pour
me booster un peu
il n'a pas envoyé un texto
vers 10 heures sofiane rentrer à
l'appartement
j'ai ressenti qui avait j'avais un truc
joue de l'apport et
et ça sentait il y avait une odeur
bizarre ça sentait la poudre et j'ai vu
mon père était en face de moi en bas des
escaliers de la mezzanine et y avait du
sang partout
mohamed dridi a été abattu au saut du
lit il a reçu une balle de gros calibre
dans le coup
aucune trace adn ni empreintes ne sont
relevés sur la scène de crime
la porte de l'appartement n'a pas été
fracturé
rien n'a été volé à l'intérieur
pour les policiers tout semble indiquer
que mohamed dridi a été victime d'une
exécution
c'est un professionnel qui connaissait
les lieux et qui connaissent l
appartement et qui connaissait la
personne ne va pas arriver
dans un bâtiment sécurisé comme ça
rentre dans un appartement aussi
facilement le dire le tueur aurait
attendu que le fils de mohamed dridi
sorte faire son jogging avant de
s'engouffrer dans l'immeuble comme
semble nous le confirmer ce voisin s'est
passé c'est que la personne s'est
introduit avec quelqu'un d'autre qui
pare balles voilà c'est un monsieur qui
est acquis
ensuite le tueur serait monté à
l'appartement 303 utilisant peut-être un
silencieux comme le laisse penser le
témoignage d'une autre voisine
n importe quel coup de feu n'a aucun
coup de feu entendu un grand boum c'est
tout un grand bruit comme il faisait du
sport avec ses alter et du sol
a appris qu'il était mort je pensais que
c'était un couple de mois
un scénario qui hantent sofiane depuis
le drame
je m'en veux encore que je me dis
surtout le plus c'est si j'avais pas été
couverts
ou si cette fois ci je sais pas j'avais
juste fermé la porte à clef
qui en voulait à momo dridi au point de
le faire exécuter
qui était vraiment cet homme au parcours
chaotique
claude dridi et le père de mohamed ils
nous racontent les fêlures de son fils
la lutte est encore un berceau et la
lvcc première pas
c'était un avant durable
[Musique]
ça c'est le jeune momo dridi avec sa
mère
en réalité mohamed dridi est un enfant
adopté arrivés de tunisie à 8 mois chez
nadine et claude dridi pendant des
années le petit mohamed ignore tout de
ses origines mais lorsqu'il a 11 ans ses
cousins lui apprenne brutalement la
vérité elle est l'amie de toute façon
sapin ton père
tient à adopter
à la
chine mme
savary morte et
il est devenu un peu brutal
parce qu'il est parti comme je me bats
pour faire
s'ensuit une vie entre box et banditisme
car momo s'est cogné comme personne
boxeur professionnel bridi va atteindre
des sommets en 1994 il remporte un
premier titre de champion du monde de
kickboxing une consécration un titre
qu'il obtient quatre fois dans sa
carrière
sofiane son fils a assisté à de très
nombreux combats tout est là quoi et
charismatique il est
voilà on voit le grand champion c'était
fin
le palmarès de mohamed dridi est
impressionnant 77 victoires dont 76 par
k o même lors parler j'ai des frissons
parce que c'était quand vous avez quoi
les 2000 3000 personnes qui tient à
campo de paix enfin c'est me souviens
m'ont crié dridi dridi enfin c'était là
l'ambiance l'environnement ça vous met
la chair de poule et encore plus quand
c'est votre corps qui va combattre je
sais quand tu joues à 42 ans il tente un
come back et fait l'objet de plusieurs
reportages
après six années loin des rings momo
dridi avait besoin de retrouver
l'ambiance des salles d'entraînement
besoin de retrouver la boxe et de se
lancer un nouveau défi le message
vis-à-vis des jeunes des quartiers tout
ça c'est de montrer que même à 42 et 46
on peut faire si on décide dans la tête
de le faire le corpus yeux
mais après quelques combats de gala le
champion raccroche les gants grâce à sa
petite notoriété momo le boxeur
s'imagine un avenir d'acteurs à la
belmondo
il rêve de paillettes et fait son entrée
dans la jet set ces nouveaux amis joey
starr jean claude van damme mêmes ivana
trump il connaît son heure de gloire à
la sortie de son livre
publié chez michel lafon ali qui
s'appelle moment le turbulent sous-titré
de la voyoucratie à la jet set avait un
peu people ouais j'ai fait qu'elle est
dans les soirées people mais j'ai fait
j'ai fait quelques soirées j'ai fait
quelques photos et j'ai fait aussi
guillaume cherel et son biographe il a
partagé ses virées nocturnes et raconter
comment momo le boxeur est devenu une
personnalité des soirées people ils
s'adaptent à ces gens là en leur
apportant ce qu'ils réclamaient donc si
c'est une femme qui sont venus au lit
avec son mari ça sera du sexe 6ème à
simon gardien mois jeudi les noms
qui sont nuit et qu'ils ont sur besoin
de gens qui ont des histoires à raconter
mon bol turbulent il avait trente six
histoires à raconter parce qu'il avait
le sens de la formule ça me fascine et
un peu parce qu'ils se disent neige
pourrait peut-être faire du cinéma mais
en fait il est très vite et on lui
momo dridi ne perce pas parmi les stars
ni sur grand écran
il poursuit en revanche une carrière
beaucoup plus obscures pendant des
années il est l'homme de main de la
famille hornec les parrains de montreuil
des grands noms du banditisme
michel marie journaliste a été un ami
proche de dridi pendant 15 ans il avait
été longtemps le pas le porte-flingue
mais le le mec qui faisait le coup de
poing le type qui qui allait mettre un
coup de pression une boîte de nuit pour
faire monter une affaire de racket c'est
vrai quand on voyait débarquer dans une
boîte de nuit tout le monde était
trouillomètre à zéro parce que l'idée
monté tout ça mais qui est égal de plier
un poteau de sens interdit d'un coup
pied
ça fait peur quoi mais ce n'est pas tout
l'homme de main auraient trempé dans des
affaires beaucoup plus graves notamment
l'escroquerie à la taxe carbone
cette fois ci il n'est plus question de
petits raquette mais d'énormes sommes
d'argent et de règlements de comptes en
série no taxe carbone c'est les
milliards qui aurait été détourné avec
je ne sais combien de flingage
il est proche de ces gens là il a il a
les pieds dedans je sais pas ce qui est
je sais pas quelle est sa participation
dans cette histoire je sais qu'en tout
cas il quitte paris parce qu'ils
allaient un type qui le qu'ils cherchent
et ce type d'ailleurs sera sera
assassiné quelques temps plus tard
dridi quitte la capitale des ménages de
ville en ville avant de s'installer à
palavas il y a un an il travaille deux
fois par semaine comme videur dans une
boîte de nuit payer 200 euros la soirée
1600 euros par mois pas forcément
suffisant pour l'ancien boxeur
à court d'argent momo aurait t'il repris
du service en jouant les gros bras c'est
ce qui se raconte aujourd'hui dans le
milieu de la nuit locale
à ce titre
il est arrivé ce qui est arrivé à dijon
il a dû arriver c'est vital d'un
bombardé des mecs mais c'est avec la
bonne raison ils ont cherché donc pris
des coups
dans les restaurants
depuis quelques mois dridi était même
proche d'un ancien boxeur comme lui
condamnée pour racket
momo at-il trempé dans des affaires
locales sept-îles attirer des ennuis
auprès des parrains de la région c'est
l'une des pistes envisagées par les
enquêteurs du srpj de montpellier
autre hypothèse pouvons expliquer sa
mort un contrat lancé par le milieu
parisien lié à son passé
sofiane son fils attend des réponses
la police elle fait son enquête
elle trouve voilà c'est comme ça après
je suis pas dans une vendetta je suis
j'essaie de me reconstruire et et aller
de l'avant voilà
l'enquète sur la mort de mohamed dridi
est toujours en cours